وزير الخارجيه القطري ااا صرح في اليومين
الاخيره كانت تصريحات مكثفه حول هذا
الموضوع لان ايضا الهجمه صارت مكثفه
وتعالت الحده مؤخرا قال بان النفاق عدم
موضوعيه ازدواجيه المعايير هي السبب وراء
ذلك تبعنا في فيلم الليله رصد لمواقف بعض
الدول نتحدث عن جهات ايضا اما في بريطانيا
كانت جهه اعلاميه وراء الموضوع في الدنيا
مارك الاتحاد كره القدم همم يعني عده جهات
كانت وراء هذه همم الانتقادات
وراينا ايضا في المقابل بانها ليست ايديها
ليست بريئه تماما يعني هناك ازدواجيه
حقيقيه في المعايير انتم كيف تعاملتم مع
هذه الانتقادات منذ البدايه
طبعا احنا موضوع الانتقادات في انتقادات
لازم يتمرد عليها ان كان رد اعلامي ان كان
رد قانوني طبعا ليس كل شيء يكون على
المراه الجميع في بعض الانتقادات
على المراه الجميع يعني وسائل الاعلام
العالميه لم تدخر جهدا في ذلك وكانت حملها
شرسه وهنا كمان
انه لم يكن مستوى رد الفعل من قبل قطر على
مستوى الهجمه التي حدثت
هذه البطوله والتركيز على تنظيم هذه
البطوله باكمال الوجه همم في بعض
الانتقادات اللي صارت طبعا احنا على 12
سنه انتقادات تعودنا عليها في انتقادتها
كثير ردينا عليها بشكل صريح على في
الوسائل الاعلاميه وفي بعضها لا تستحق
الرد عليها جرائد صفراء يعني يمكن نقدر
نقول لحين ان كل الجرائد اللي احنا كنا
همم نتوقع منها المصداقيه نتوقع منها
الشفافيه
المسؤوليه المهنيه في في في المجال صارت
كلها جرائد صفراء للاسف